we want to talk about a national
embarrassment
Joe Biden
Joe Biden is making his beg for oil tour
around the Middle East
and Biden really irked a lot of people
not just on the right
but especially on the left over at the
end of last week because he shows up to
Saudi Arabia and basically just begs the
Crown Prince for oil
the reason for this is that Joe Biden
shut down new oil and gas production in
the United States and shut down new oil
pipelines even though he gave the green
light to an oil pipeline for Vladimir
Putin he's giving the green light he's
actually begging the Middle Eastern Oil
States to produce more oil but he's just
not producing American Oil I guess Saudi
Arabian oil doesn't pollute the
environment in the way that American oil
does it doesn't make sense to me but
that must be the premise here I don't
know why it's okay for Saudi Arabia to
produce oil and profit from that but
it's not okay for Americans to do the
very same so he's going around he's
begging people to get more oil and the
thing that really irked the left was he
goes to Saudi Arabia and he gives a fist
bump to the Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman
now this is embarrassing I want again it
gets to this issue of national dignity I
want my leaders to not behave like
teenagers you know I'd been nice
handshake would be good sturdy hand
shake it but okay it gives the fist bump
fine whatever the reason the lips are
upset by the fist bump is that for the
past
three four years or longer they have
been painting Muhammad bin Salman as the
worst terrible murderous monster
Barbarian in the entire world and the
reason they've done that
or the reason that they've been able to
make this argument is because the head
of Saudi Arabia Muhammad bin Salman
killed assassinated the that
disinterested symbol of Journalism Jamal
khashoggi
do you remember Jamal khashoggi Jamaica
maybe you don't remember it I mean the
news Cycles move so fast now Jamal
khashoggi here's here is the story that
was presented about Jamal khashoggi he
was a journalist a reporter a columnist
for the Washington Post who was just
minding his own business in turkey and
the Saudi Crown Prince sent his thugs
his assassins to the to the residents
where Jamal khashoggi was staying and
they chopped him up and they tortured
him and they killed him because he was
speaking truth to power and he was a
disinterested journalist and this was an
attack on the fourth estate and the Free
Press everywhere
and that's not what happened that's not
what happened at all
the Jamal khashoggi story was just
complete propaganda Jamal khashoggi was
a political operative and a spy he was
not in any reasonable use of the term a
journalist Jamal khashoggi had been a
spy for Saudi Arabia he had been a spy
for Saudi Arabia's enemies he had palled
around and worked with Osama Bin Laden
back in the early days of al-Qaeda he
was on the payroll of Qatar he would
have these foreign interests draft
sometimes write whole portions of the
columns that he would submit to The
Washington Post and other Publications
he was an influence Peddler he was a
political operative he had been on the
good side of parts of the Saudi royal
family then he fell on the bad bad side
of parts of the soil Saudi royal family
and he was working for some of the Saudi
enemies so the Saudis did what the
Saudis do what a lot of states do and
they went out and assassinated their
enemies I'm not I'm not defending the
assassination of the enemies of Saudi
Arabia but I am saying this is kind of
par for the course
and it's very different than the story
that had been presented which is that
Saudi Arabia was attacking the Free
Press that's not it at all what you saw
playing out there
with the assassination of Jamal
khashoggi and really the subsequent
media spin around it is you saw two
competing interests especially in the
United States
the libs went crazy over the killing of
Jamal khashoggi because the libs hate
Saudi Arabia they want us to back away
from Saudi Arabia and our relationship
there and they want us to Cozy up to
Iran
the conservatives tend to think that
we're better with the devil we know than
the devil we don't and they prefer that
we remain allies with Saudi Arabia and
that we don't cozy up to Iran and we
don't give Iran pallets of cash and we
don't give Iran a nuclear weapon
and so and there are a lot of other
Regional Powers at play there as well so
the libs pounced on the Jamal khashoggi
killing to try to generate
worldwide opposition to Saudi Arabia and
to get people to Cozy up more to Iran
it was just it was just a propaganda
operation to shift certain geopolitical
alliances and the reason I mentioned it
is because a lot of people fell for it
the Washington Post is still
going crazy over the killing of Jamal
khashoggi as some attack on the press
and a lot of people fell for it because
they violate the first rule when you are
reading any news story talked about this
a couple weeks ago but it's really
important to keep in mind when you are
reading a news report about any story
domestic foreign economic crime
immigration whatever the first question
you have to ask yourself before you even
get to the the facts the who what where
when why
you have to ask you have to ask a why
question about the story itself you have
to ask what is the angle
when you read the New York Times when
you're reading the daily wire when
you're reading anything in between you
need to ask yourself okay what is the
angle here why is this story being
reported
Now by this news Outlet
why
journalism costs money
people are putting their resources in a
certain place so people are going to
make decisions on how to deploy those
resources there are always political
considerations that come into that so
you've got to ask yourself and it's just
particular it's true across the
political Spectrum but it's particularly
egregious when we're talking about the
Washington Post or the New York Times
where they're huge entrenched corrupt
interests that fund these papers what is
the angle why is this being reported now
why am I being told that the the
assassination of an ex-saudi spy is the
worst attack on a free press in the
history of the world and you realize it
actually has nothing to do with Jamal
khashoggi has nothing to do with the
press it has nothing to do with
Washington Post it has everything to do
with giant political forces trying to
restructure the world order right now go
to Helix sleep.com slash Knowles I have
had my Helix mattress for a little under
a year and a half and I absolutely love
it I adore it one it's super easy to
unbox they bring it right to your house
boom boom boom it opens up super easy
you sleep like never before it's just so
wonderful tailored exactly to your sleep
preferences the way they do that
they've got a quiz that takes two
minutes to complete matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you with Helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way that you
sleep everyone's unique Helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models to choose from soft medium and
firm mattresses mattresses great for
cooling you down if you sleep hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains I
just love it absolutely cannot recommend
these guys enough you do not need to go
to the mattress store ever again go to
helixsleep.com Knowles take their
two-minute sleep quiz they will match
you to a customized mattress give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10 year warranty you can try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up if you don't love it but you
will love it for a limited time get up
to 350 off all mattress orders plus two
free pillows for our listeners it's
their best offer yet hurry over to
helixsleep.com
there's a there's a new BLM Idol that's
out there you might you might have
missed this one if you were out having a
barbecue with your family this weekend
you might have missed that a new BLM
Idol dropped this person is teclay
Sundberg
techley Sundberg uh was a young man who
uh according to investigators fired
multiple gunshots inside a Seward
neighborhood uh in Minneapolis uh and
inside this apartment building on
Wednesday night and so the police were
called they were trying to talk this guy
down they were trying to get the guy to
surrender the guy just would not
surrender and eventually the cops killed
him and now there are BLM demonstrations
people showing up justice for Tech clay
he was killed by the racist Minneapolis
cops because he's a black man and they
were making their demonstrations
which were interrupted by a really
inconvenient person for the BLM crowd
the inconvenient person would be the
victim who was almost murdered with her
two little kids by Tecla Sundberg
[Music]
shut up
shut up
unarmed
what's on our you're alive I'm sorry
this is not okay you're alive the bullet
missed you so stop complaining
[Music]
of course the kids are traumatized
kitchen
stop complaining you didn't you didn't
die you almost did it
she's obviously going through a moment
yeah she and her two kids were almost
killed
now you're complaining that the guy is
shot in that shot
oh
wow
shut up
this woman comes up guessing
imagine you're a mother
and you say I mean you really you
totally feel for this one she's saying
this guy tried to kill me and my
children
but me in front of my kids or my
children in front of me or all of us at
once
and you are all
crying because this guy was taken out by
police before he could successfully kill
me and my children and now you're really
upset that he wasn't allowed to keep
shooting do you see how that's kind of
offensive to me
and BLM doesn't care you heard the the
protesters out there say shut up you're
fine there's bullet holes in my wall
yeah there's not bullet holes in you
shut up it's not about you it's about
our narrative our and our according to
our narrative this guy who was shooting
you through your walls and almost killed
your kids he was a poor innocent victim
but he was probably unarmed I don't know
where those bullets came from and you
need to shut up and stop contradicting
our narrative or else I'm glad you liked
that clip we are about two people away
from hitting a million subscribers I
don't know what the actual number is but
we are so close to 1 million that's
going to be great they're going to send
me a big gold play button and then
almost certainly they're going to Nuke
my channel right they're not going to
let me get over a million subscribers so
let's do it baby let's just let's go out
in the blaze of glory ring that Bell
subscribe get the notifications we'll
see you next time
[Music]
thank you